all right it looks like we're now
live for the may
ask me anything that is ama session
and um got some questions lined up here
already um
the first of which is going to be i
don't care
answer but
thoughts on ukraine neo-nazis the azov
battalion c-14 rights sector i don't
really give a [ __ ] about that
um i think this is a great example of
people who don't have a very good sense
of proportion
if you're worried about the fact that
there are in fact
hard right neo-nazis
involved in the ukrainian forces but not
as like the totality of them
and you're not focusing on the just
naked aggression committed by putin
and his regime in russia then you know
it's almost not worth
thinking about or engaging with you it's
sort of like the people who always want
to do what about ism
and they're focused on the most trivial
of stuff and ignoring the the larger
issues so i'm going to
skip over jack's second question maybe
we'll come back to it later generally i
like to take um one question from one
person at a time
uh chris your thoughts on the recent
support supreme court drama seasoned
with your philosophical perspective
well um so i do have a lot of thoughts
on the recent supreme court drama which
is that it's not recent supreme court
drama it's it's one part of a much
bigger
picture the supreme court has
essentially been corrupted as a
political institution i would say from
the obama administration when the
republicans
refused to give hearings and started
packing the court themselves under the
trump administration and we've got some
pretty unqualified
people that that snuck in um
who are you know espousing some very
extreme views
and this has been part of a strategy on
the part of republicans i won't say
conservatives because republicans aren't
really conservatives anymore
in the traditional sense in american
politics they're more radicals
and i mean i saw this this sort of
discourse happening way back in the 90s
when i would go to these notre dame
center for ethics and culture
conferences and they would be talking
about the abortion issue and the need to
infiltrate the uh the supreme court and
also the federal courts and all that
sort of stuff so the republicans have
been you know for the last 20 odd years
pretty clear about what it is that they
intend to do
and then they put up justices who lied
who perjured themselves on the stand in
order to get
uh the rather foolish democrats to go
along
with them and allow them in
and i think you know the fact that
roe versus wade it looks like it's going
to be overturned along with casey versus
pennsylvania and that there's other
important rights-based cases that have
to do with the the right to privacy that
look like they're going to get
overturned by this court
i think it's going to be pretty major
it's going to lead to some really
significant
activism the question is whether the
country as a whole and as particular
states has lurched so far into the hands
of republican minority
rule uh that maybe some of it's going to
be ineffective but we'll see what ends
up happening
with that
um zeno uh i was wondering what your
thoughts are on show open hours the
world is will and representation i
picked up a copy and i'm excited to read
it uh it's a great book it's it's
certainly well worth reading
schopenhauer is a very interesting
thinker
um he's at his best when he's doing his
own sort of productive work he's at his
worst when he's talking about
talking polemically about other figures
so pretty much everything he has to say
about hegel you should take as
schopenhauer being a jealous old grump
who can't hold himself back from
disparaging people and this appears to
be a then part of his character his
letter from his mother who's criticizing
him basically for being a pretentious
[ __ ] uh shows this to be you know not
just a matter of him versus hegel but
but something that kind of characterized
his thinking but he's he's very uh
thoughtful and
um his you know what he's doing there
engaging kant also thinking in terms of
uh you know other thinkers as well
particularly plato
is
well worth reading through it's it's one
of those books that you know you could
say like descartes meditations or
um i mean everybody loves kant's first
critique but actually the second
critique is much more interesting and
the third critique is too
um or you know hobbes leviathan or you
know several different books by
aristotle including the nick of mccain
ethics they're sort of like
must reads along the way i would say you
know not because if you haven't read it
you're you're totally lacking something
but why would you deprive yourself of
the opportunity to read somebody cool
like that
mark
says hey everybody hope you're doing
well this weekend i hope you're doing
well too mark down in south africa and
let's take the next one
uh here's a good one
rob says do you think eclecticism
necessitates synthesis
eclecticism doesn't necessitate anything
i mean that's part of the freedom of
being an eclectic there's multiple ways
of being an eclectic
um i resonate with the philosophical
eclecticism you've previously described
your eclectics need to bring together
these different views i mean you can
it's another live possibility
i'll albeit one that you know condemns
you to superficiality
and sort of consumerism on a
philosophical scale but it's certainly a
viable option
is to just you know be what i call a
smorgasbord eclectic and a smorgasbord
is a buffet it's it's that's a
scandinavian term that made its way into
culture here in the midwest
and probably swedish i'm guessing
and you know some people are eclectics
they just like pick a little bit of this
and a little bit of this and a little
bit of this i would say by the way
all those people doing their quote sites
even if they claim that they're like you
know epicureans or stoics or something
like that if they're not actually
reading the text
they don't know whether the quotes are
real quotes and their eclectics without
even realizing it and basically just
superficial smorgasbord eclectics if
like camus says in the myth of sisyphus
you think that consistency
with yourself is a value well then
you're probably going to be driven
towards something like what rob here is
calling synthesis the the need to
take different points of view and try to
try to harmonize them or bring them
together while recognizing
where there are significant differences
that that you know you can't evade
um but i don't think that there is a
absolute
necessity to that i mean it's it's kind
of up to you
as the thinker it's your brain it's kind
of up to you what you want to do you
know
all right let's take a look at the next
one
um ridicule do you think chomsky's
libertarian socialism is consistent with
many enlightenment principles as he
claims
has the development of capitalism
gradually perverted classic liberal
ideas so two different questions there
one is i don't know i mean i don't pay
much attention to chomsky's uh stuff
these days myself
so i'm not really a great person to
qualify or to to answer that in any
competent way i will say this though
that's the second question is a really
good one
has the development of capitalism
gradually perverted classic liberal
ideas so classical liberal ideals were
never that great to begin with right so
we're talking about you know like lock
and people along those lines um
and
you know they were always kind of
ideology playing itself out as if it's
completely neutral anyway i mean there's
plenty of critiques out there about this
and
you know somebody like jon stewart mill
was able to recognize that some of these
things needed to be like rethought in
the new times that we're in
when i hear somebody call themselves a
classic liberal i usually just sort of
write them off in my brain
as being somebody who's an ideologue and
doesn't want to deal with the pressing
problems of the time and wants to you
know say well there's the conservatives
on this side and the
liberals on this side and i'm kind of in
the middle and all that um and and it's
in part because
the
traditional classical liberal stuff
yeah it's not just that it hasn't like
adjusted to the way that capitalism
itself has changed capitalism isn't just
one thing capitalism is a whole sequence
of different things that are connected
to each other in interesting ways
so
yeah i mean i i would say that
it's certainly something i teach and
talk about in classes but i
i don't really take that seriously when
i see people espousing it
jack has a thing
the neo-nazi groups have threatened
zelinski's life if he signs the minsk
agreement 1400 dead since 2014
predominantly on the separatist side i'm
worried about arming another muhaji
mujahideen
type scenario so
i guess the thing that you have to think
about
and that helps put this in perspective
what is the proportion of the neo-nazi
groups to the totality of the ukrainian
uh fighting forces
if they're 30
which they're not
um then maybe you know we would be
arming uh neo-nazi groups who are not
the same thing as radical islamists
um
but because you know i don't think
they're going to be exporting terrorism
over to the united states as the you
know the great satan or anything like
that um so you do want to like preserve
some some difference between these
things rather than blur them all
together
um if it's a much smaller percentage
then we're not we're not focusing on
arming neo-nazi groups are we so it's
kind of a red herring
um or a distraction i would say
uh coming back so mark uh says been
thinking about discipline lately and i
was wondering if it should be thought of
as a character virtue
or something which is a prelude to
virtue how would it relate to something
like encrateam so encroatea is a word
that means
endurance uh but it also means
um self-mastery being you know um being
in control of yourself
and or carte is rather endurance um and
so for it depends on whose virtue ethics
we're looking at right so
if we're looking at
aristotle where i'm thinking mark is
probably coming from
then
there's a distinction between
self-control and cratea and actually
having virtue and it is a prelude to
virtue
for
um aristotle first you're you're in
craddock you're in control of yourself
you do the right thing even though you
don't necessarily want to do it and then
after a while you develop the virtue and
now you actually want to do the right
thing and you feel good while you're
doing it so
if you look at it that way then yeah it
is it is kind of a precursor uh to
virtue
and you know it's
def more difficult for some people with
some things to have
self-control than it is for for other
people with other things aristotle
recognizes we have also what are called
the natural virtues which are the
beginnings you could say of virtue
if we're looking at things maybe from
the stoic perspective then this might
actually be part of
temperance or
part of courage or something like that
right
so
um
joseph
says that he
bungled his question onto theology stuff
what in heidegger do you disagree with
and then he says you mentioned
jean-luc's marion project is not
something you were into that much and i
was wondering about it so i i think a
lot of this talk about onto theology i
don't really
buy into it that much i think it was
kind of a dead end um we don't need
fancy terms like that in order to say
people have misconstrued
um
uh the divine as simply being in a
metaphysical sense that's basically what
what it comes down to if you peel away
all the
fancy
terminology and the sometimes hysterics
about it and you know the fact that
people make entire careers out of
decrying onto theology if you really get
at the heart of it
that's what it is and you can say well
you know um there's something to that
but uh it's not as if western
metaphysics has always been caught up in
that you can point to plenty of
theological
thinkers that way and you can also
question what was heidegger right about
that in the first place and is mario
right to continue sort of as a critic of
heidegger but basically a follower of
heidegger in that path
and i think the answer is no so
um
roughly says thank you for your alchemy
of york videos i'd never heard of the
guy before your post so they were a real
treat yeah there's all these
great thinkers
that
are worth reading
that um don't generally make it into the
let's call it the the canon or the
circles
of the people who write the intro to
philosophy books or who you know
um
you know do the popular philosophy
online in part because those people
didn't have a good enough education even
if they went to oxford or harvard or
places like that you can still get a
shitty education at those places as a
matter of fact it's almost easier to
because you're convinced that what your
professors are doing is like the real
stuff and you know whatever anybody else
is doing is isn't really that important
and so unless you're like a medievalist
you're probably not going to run across
alcuin but he's he's an interesting uh
thinker from the carolingian renaissance
and he has a lot of cool stuff to say in
his works and there's lots and lots and
lots of thinkers like that
throughout the um the history of
philosophy
it you know there's kind of a vicious
circle
where if if the people you know
aren't mentioning them because they
haven't read them and don't know about
them
then you don't know that they're
actually interesting and important so
you don't spend the time to read them
and then you become the next generation
of people
who
haven't um who haven't read them right
that's kind of a big problem
um you know the guy did my dissertation
on maurice blondell
great example if you say below
if you say blondel to begin with
nietzsche scholars will think that
you're talking about eric blondell and
then everyone else would be like who's
that are you do you mean bergstone and
you know then you say no no blondel was
doing what bergstone was doing about you
know
five to ten years earlier
but he is in that generation
and then you know uh then you start
explaining about him and people are like
oh i've never heard of that guy well
yeah cause uh we don't we don't talk
about him that much um
all right uh arthur which philosopher do
you admire most as a person that's a
great question um and that's way better
than like what people often ask me which
is who's your favorite philosopher and i
don't have an answer to that
as a person
that's also a tough one because i i do
know some people in the the business who
i
admire considerably like aleister
mcintyre who i've you know
gotten to know a bit over the years not
just by reading his works but
interacting with him
um and there's there's certainly a lot
of traits that are admirable admirable
about him or about you know chris
christopher gill or
uh quite a few other people but um if
we're going back into
time
you know i'm gonna just sort of pull
somebody out of the air
i really like mary wollstonecraft
um
she had a rough life
she made the best of it that she could
she didn't always exemplify exactly what
her
written positions were in her own
personal life but she certainly
made a stab at it she overcame
incredible difficulties
i think she's pretty admirable
it's unfortunate she died so young and
that her husband william godwin messed
up her reputation with his uh
imprudent tell-all biography of her so
um
your average french-canadian immigrant
i've been reading a lot of cognitive
science recently how should a
philosopher read cogside without
dogmatically accepting claims how do you
read or use cockside well you said it
right there
don't dogmatically accept claims
that are made by supposed cognitive
science people i mean i say suppose it
because a lot of cognitive science is
not really scientific
it's science-y
but you know
whether or not it's it's
genuinely you know scientific that
remains to be seen if we actually
believe in what science is supposed to
be
a lot of the studies that are done are
on way too few subjects with huge
sweeping conclusions drawn from what we
observe in an mri machine very
artificial circumstances
with lots of dubious assumptions built
in so you know you want to keep that in
mind right
a lot of what they're a lot of what
people do in cognitive science any
especially more in cognitive science
journalism
is make sweeping dogmatic assumptions
that are not going to hold up over time
and i suppose you could remind yourself
that a lot of
uh present-day science you know when it
comes to
cognitive science or social science or
stuff like that is like one step removed
from the phrenology
and physiognomy that hegel critiqued so
well in the phenomenology of spirit by
the way i mentioned mcintyre he's got a
great
piece um
on that chapter in the edited volume
that he brought forth on hegel
i want to say it's called hegel on bones
and skulls and so that's that's worth
checking out
uh jack just doesn't want to let this go
right what's the adequate threshold of
nazis i don't [ __ ] know i mean
why are you so obsessed with this this
topic um
that might be something you want to
devote some
thought to
uh obviously the more that there are the
more problematic it is but
again
bigger fish to fry so
you know
um
i think no nazi battalions is best yeah
i mean i think that no corrupt police
here in milwaukee would be best too or
nobody getting coveted would be best or
we could go down the line about all
sorts of ideal utopian things but how
about we live in the real world where
we're a little bit more realistic about
this kind of thing you know
all right sergio what do you think about
dumbet's perspective in the future of
philosophy that every branch of
philosophy should study should be
studied with focus on the analysis of
the language i think that's silly um i
mean dumbet is a creature of his time
and
and philosophical culture
it's important to attend to language
analytic philosophy at least some of the
analytic philosophy of the 20th century
was good for pointing that out as was a
lot of the continental philosophy as was
classical american philosophy as was we
go back in time right this idea that
like oh we figured out in the 20th
century that we need to pay attention to
language nobody who actually knows the
history of philosophy well uh buys into
that and it's a silly perspective um so
i mean that's about all i think i have
to say about that
uh joseph like what are your what are
your most fundamental issues with the
heidegger of being in time
um
[Music]
well they don't have to do with onto
theology at all they have to do with the
fact that heidegger very clearly
um in his you know critique of epical
metaphysics that's going to develop in
his works
makes a fundamental mistake that mock
shaler doesn't make
namely
to think that any
perspective that would be fundamentally
oriented by
values right or ethical questions
um is in a way a
you know sort of restriction of being to
to
those perspectives heidegger is just
wrong about that i mean i also think
he's wrong too to consider that anxiety
is the fundamental disclose of mood
adrian pepper zach
from you know
dutch dutch phenomenologist who's done a
lot of work on levine us and hegel over
the years and who's a
professor emeritus from loyola down in
chicago
pointed this out in in the 90s in some
essays that you can find in his his
books from then
i think he's right about that um
i don't think that anxiety is the mood
per se for disclosure i don't want to
say that every single mood is
um and you know there's other places
where you might you know you might
quibble with heidegger about that but
those are some of the big ones
um
for me
um
elijah how can one integrate lacan and
blondel's insights into finding
fulfillment secure relationships in a
secure sense of self how can blondels
logic and ontology inform lacanian
psychoanalysis i don't think that it has
to
and i'm not sure that they're
sharing enough assumptions in common
for that to be a viable project i don't
know why you'd necessarily want to do
that
um
so
i mean
i think it's better to to do things like
say
how can we draw this idea from this
thinker into this
right but i mean lacan is his own kind
of
thing his own project over here and
blondel's doing a different project over
here where there's going to be some
overlap but they're you're not going to
like synthesize them into
one coherent perspective i would say
um
mossack as a christian how do you
respond to the claim who big claims that
christianity was not special in terms of
account of genesis and revelation in
general but the concept of jesus is god
was not new well the concept of jesus is
god was certainly new because nobody
else or before was saying that jesus
this guy you know from nazareth was was
god um you're probably talking about the
mythicist people who are you know like
well you know there was also like
resurrection with the unesses and you
know hercules got got brought up to
heaven and stuff like that yeah sure
i mean how do you respond to it you say
yeah i mean uh who the hell is claiming
that jesus uh being god is an absolutely
totally unprecedented there were no
prefigurations of it absolutely unique
thing
and your answer will be kooks
because you know when you look at the
church fathers
they'll be they'll say you know
things like well for example clement of
alexandria right uh the jews had what
he's he's calling the old testament what
we typically call the hebrew scriptures
now the greeks had greek philosophy both
are precursors to the gospel right
you have all sorts of other polemics
along the line but even when they're
engaging in these polemics and saying
this is different they're also saying
this is different than what we
acknowledge to be cases like hercules
being deified or you know other things
like that so
um
i would say you know avoid the the kooky
people who are obsessed with those sorts
of claims myself
uh ben
says been reading carol adams the sexual
politics of meat that sounds like an
interesting one i'm not vegan but her
thesis is compelling
i don't know what her thesis is because
i haven't read the book also just got
done reading a bunch of plato onto
aristotle i'm starting with politics
well that that that's good you know
all right nate have you read nussbaum's
work on anger if so do you have any
thoughts yeah i read it when it came out
i've got it on my shelves i've been
meaning to review it i think nussbaum as
usual gets some things right and
something's wrong and you know um
she's uh she's certainly somebody who
has had many many opportunities to get
to
study the texts
and uh often you know contributes useful
perspectives but i think she also
sometimes
gets them wrong so
i'm not a big fan of nussbaum
frankly
m.c what do you think of the early
german romantics like schlegel i'm folk
i'm planning on focusing my philosophy
research on those thinkers i think those
are people that i haven't read much and
what i did read was a long time ago so i
don't really have an opinion on them
uh adwin what's my favorite kind of
pizza
um well i i like a lot of different
kinds i like
this this version i'll say my favorite
pizza place here in milwaukee is ian's
pizza which has uh really really good
pizzas very thin crust you know
that sort of thing milwaukee typically
is known for
and i i like two kinds in particular i
really like the one that's got
ham and pineapple and jalapenos on it
that's pretty good but i also
like um you know a good
sausage and onion and green peppers and
black olives pizza as well but all you
know i'm not a particularly picky guy
i'll eat pretty much
anything that's put in front of me
uh zeno is there a self um yeah i think
there's a self i think that you have a
self and i've got a self and you know
human beings have selves i know that
there are different philosophical
perspectives that say that there isn't a
self very often you have to ask well
what do you mean by a self you know it's
sort of like debating about free will
before you actually clarify what people
mean by it oftentimes you find out that
person a is saying x is not the case
and
what you're saying is well y actually is
the case and they're not exactly the the
same thing
writerly urge do you think form and
content are distinct or are they bound
up with each other form and content are
relative terms right um
i don't see how you're gonna have a form
without content uh or content that
doesn't have some sort of form but what
counts as form and content varies
considerably
from instance to instance and sometimes
form and content are not the most useful
terms i mean should we talk about form
and content with the taste of the coffee
that i've got right here i don't know
how that's particularly
helpful
um
god says do you find a response to hume
skepticism i.e
sufficient
i i think hume skepticism is incoherent
so i don't think you even need to go to
kant
um
i mean
there's so many places where
hume is a great rhetorician
but when you start pulling away and you
start you know applying him to himself
you're like
this doesn't hold up um
so
i i don't know that you have to have a
conscience
response is kant's response to hume
sufficient i mean it's sufficient if you
want to turn the entire universe into
stuff that we
you know is partly out there and partly
it's our projection onto it i don't know
that we necessarily
uh benefit from going that way
that's a lot of baby with the bath water
throwing out isn't it
uh useless projects i'm sorry if someone
already asked you this question before
well not at least in this this
particular session but people are always
asking me about it
have you read any of slavo zijk's books
and what are your thoughts on his work
i've yeah i've read slavo zuzak i mean i
first encountered him back in graduate
school
and my wife has studied at european
graduate school where he teaches
i think that g-jack is is okay um i
don't think that
a hundred years from now he's gonna be
somebody that we're we're reading and
like oh yeah a really major figure
um but you know i could be wrong about
that i find that he's a little bit too
free associationist and bring everything
in and connect everything together
in in a way that's typical of
continental theorists
that i don't find particularly
congenial
sometimes he has interesting things to
say that are worth considering
sometimes he seems to be just riffing
and bullshitting and
you know you have to devote a good bit
of time to figuring out which is which i
i would say
i certainly don't think he deserves the
aura that people surround him with um
gabriel how can we deal with the flaws
of representative democracy that's such
a big picture question
um that there isn't really an answer
an easy answer to it right it kind of
depends on which representative
democracy we're talking about like are
we talking about it in america or in
sweden or in iraq you know
we have different uh problems that are
in front of us here in america we're
pretty screwed
because we have this
antiquated system that has proven itself
to be very vulnerable for the last you
know
uh well at least hundred years to
corruption by special interests uh
whether from right left or center you
know a lot of corporations are not right
or left they just they just give a [ __ ]
about making money and you know doing
what they're gonna do and so our system
is uh pretty permeable to that and it
turns out that we have democratic norms
that are
not respected by one of the main parties
uh which has been veering towards
fascism uh basically since the tea party
days i would say uh but more and more
you know under the the you know trump
transformation
and we don't seem to be able to do an
awful lot about it um i don't know that
american representative democracy is
going to be
something particularly lasting and the
problem is we've got this antiquated
system that's dependent on you know an
old written constitution
that wasn't particularly
well put together
and has been you know progressively uh
by a court that appropriated the power
to review and explain it to itself
um
you know
progressively reinterpreted and
re-expanded and stuff like that in very
baroque ways
so we're kind of screwed here i think
that other places might be
better off or or have other problems you
know so
i don't know that we have a one size
solution for dealing with the flaws of
representative
democracy
peter says have you heard of the
grasshopper games life in utopia i have
not so i don't know
what to say about that
augustonism says i am curious what's
your opinion on logic and mathematics my
opinion is that it's not really
something that you would have an opinion
on
i mean i
as an undergraduate
in college i
majored in mathematics as well as
philosophy and that meant that i spent a
lot of time
studying not just you know
what we had in logic but also the
foundations of mathematics and and logic
and how to do
modeling things i actually wrote my
senior thesis on isomorphic truth
self-referential statement groups
and so you know
i think that
mathematics is
you know a vast field and you know what
do i have to say about mathematics as a
whole i guess it's great stuff and you
should study it right
and logic likewise um
but yeah i think i need something a
little bit more
[Music]
more specific to be able to answer much
uh profam i've seen many conservatives
use mcintyre to oppose transgender
people in gay marriage to my knowledge
he's never talked about these topics or
be aware of any time he's mentioned it i
am not aware and i think those
conservatives are the sort of rod rayer
types that mcintyre has explicitly
criticized uh for his stupid stupid book
the benedict option where he completely
misunderstood mcintyre and went ahead
and did his own sort of uh
uh you know
pretend conservative thing because these
conservatives are not real conservatives
they they don't actually want to
preserve a
status quo they're not standing aside
history and saying slow down or let
alone stop they're not conservative
about preserving institutions they're
all basically fascists
and they call themselves conservatives
but they're not conservatives and they
you know whatever use they're making of
mcintyre they're probably full of crap
all sorts of people have used mcintyre
for
things that he's not for
so maybe he'll say something about it
i mean i know that mcintyre himself uh
is a pretty
cool guy and a decent human being i
can't imagine that he would be happy
about
seeing uh his work used to try to take
away rights from
lgbtq people you know
luca what do you think of oswald
spengler i think he's a second rate
philosopher maybe third rate
you know which is not to say he's awful
or something like that but he's he's
definitely
you know
it's interesting the people who like are
super into oswald spangler you can
usually
tell by that fact just like people who
are super into ein rand or people who
are super into
bertrand russell for that matter um and
they think that as the best best person
ever there's something wrong with their
either their background or their
motivational structure
um or you know their emotional life or
something like that um spengler's
probably always going to be popular
because he's got you know a shtick that
people really get into just like people
are always going to be reading that that
stupid edward gibbons you know the
decline and fall of the roman empire
even though it's garbage you know and
historians for generations have been
saying
don't buy this this crap people are
going to be buying into it you know
uh cork mars why do you think leo
strauss influenced the neocons in such a
bizarre way because neocons are a bunch
of uh
people who love the sort of thing that
strauss was pandering you know the
esoteric stuff you know
strauss strauss is a good example of
another second or third rate philosopher
that you know when you know that
somebody's a straussian you could be
like well they're probably not going to
be that that worth spending time with
and talking about stuff
um i mean i've and i've used strauss in
some of the things that i've written
because he he occasionally gets things
right um or he has something interesting
to say as a foil but yeah i mean neocons
like easy stuff
um
and so they got into they got into
strauss you know
um
all right been a yuck thanks for the
great videos i'm curious you have any
favorite non-cosmic horror
novel yeah
um
philip k dicks uh scanner darkly
dick is one of my favorite authors and
used to be that man in the high castle
was my favorite uh dick novel but now i
would say it's uh scanner darkly
um so you know that could be up there i
mean
it's not it's not cosmic horror there
are some
what we might call horror elements to it
um
you know the horror of drug abuse
um and and pushing and stuff like that
but
it's it's more you know i'd say
sci-fi and sociological than anything
else so
uh rob wickline do you know anything of
object-oriented ontology yeah i know
something of it i'm not very interested
in it i think it's a project that
you know is going to be relegated to the
footnotes of history of ideas by the
time that we're all dead and gone
um
i've actually met and interacted with
graham harmon
um i just don't find what they're doing
all that revolutionary or
or you know interesting but maybe if i
spent more time on it i would i don't
know
um easter meth do you have any plans on
doing videos of critique of pure reason
in the near future um i don't unless
somebody wants to commission them
and you know that would be a pretty
significant project
commission means pay me for the time
required to do the work and
you know there's a lot of people who ask
for things but very few people who
actually want to
put their money where their mouth is i
have actually had some people like
commissioned stuff on nietzsche or
heidegger in the past shorter works you
know like truth and lies in an extra
moral sense
or heidegger's uh
on
plato's allegory of the cave but
yeah unless somebody wants to commission
that um i i've got i've got other stuff
to do i mean if i was going to do
something deliberately on a conscient
critique why would it be the critique of
pure reason when the critique of
practical reason is so much more
interesting i would say
um i'm not sure why people take the
critique of pure reason it's one of
these books with an auros or like
spinoza's ethics or hegel's
phenomenology or you know more recently
nick lands fang newman where people like
oh this is such an important work it's
actually not that important
when you look at things in the grand
sweep of the history of ideas i mean
it's a cool book but
it's not as important as people make it
out to be
and i think a lot of the people who talk
about it just haven't read it you know
and worked their way through it
so yeah i mean that's that's basically
what i have to say but i do want to
eventually maybe this summer or maybe
this fall
do some videos on the prolagomena much
shorter work that kant you know wrote as
the read this first book for the
critique
um but you know that depends on me
getting other projects done so
all right
zeno says
do you get intimidated when reading
complex works
i saw a video of you
and
cliff from better than food are you
still in contact i'm not no we haven't
we haven't remained in contact
i'm not sure what he's up to these days
he was i mean for a while he was talking
about
producing a movie version of bataille's
story of the eye and i thought that's
really cool but i don't think he's
gotten around to that and i don't know
what what he's doing these days which is
you know kind of unfortunate but we're
we're both probably both busy people
um
do i get intimidated when reading
complex works i don't get
intimidated um
i mean i've been studying philosophy
which includes some complex works
since you know in in a serious way since
i was 20 years old and i'm now 51
so
you know sometimes there are complex
works that i
can't figure out what the hell is going
on with it
and then i just leave those aside and
spend my time going on things that are
i can you know more productively
work through not all of us have to read
everything you know
so
made of clay what's the hardest you've
ever laughed at something
boy that's a great question i don't know
um
i mean there are
uh
some some you know shows that are very
very funny
and then there's like things that
somebody will say
in our you know ordinary life
and you burst out laughing or things
that happen like you see somebody
do something and it winds up being
screwed up i i don't know what's the
hardest i've laughed but i will say this
i try to find something
funny to laugh at every day
in part because i know that's important
for
um you know keeping my mood
uh
decent
and i also like to laugh you know i'm
somebody who
will joke around about stuff that some
people think is a little bit too
irreverent or you know we shouldn't joke
about that like you know death and
uh the world going wrong or stuff like
that i don't have any problem laughing
at that stuff
um
so
all right uh
let's see
kiram says i have a deep interest in
philosophy in general and study
electronics at university how can i
balance my interests with my study i
don't think that's too hard to do
figure out how much time in each day
you're spending on different things and
then decide how much time you want to
spend on your study of electronics and
how much you want to study how much you
want to spend on philosophy and then if
you find that you're you know spending
too much time on one maybe
rebalance it you know
david says i have to write a final paper
on anything existentialism related
and i'm very stuck i can't think of what
i want to argue can you offer any advice
yeah i mean
here's two topics that you could you
could approach right off the bat
do existentialists think that life is
absurd
um
well
kamu talks about the absurd a lot and
sart does
sometimes too
but what is uh
simone bouvoir title her book the ethics
of ambiguity
life is not absurd life is ambiguous
what does gabriel marcel talk about
the mystery
maybe life is mysterious so right there
right
mysterious uh ambiguous or absurd
there's a topic that you could work with
um you know another idea radical freedom
coming from jean-paul sartre
we are we all are radically free simone
de bevoir says no that's not really the
case again look at the ethics of
ambiguity
some people are more free
than others are
right
so those are some possibilities
uh peter doran what do you think about
20th and 21st century italian philosophy
gram she again been echo of course i
don't know corset uh echo um
i'm i'm very into you know i like
semiotics um first encountered his stuff
first encountered him actually
uh
with the book foucault's pendulum and
then i got into
reading his stuff we actually in in
graduate school we went over to the
speech communication department where
richard lanigan the former president of
the american semiotics association
taught classes on echo and on other
thinkers as well
um so kind of picked up a taste for him
uh gramsci i haven't read that much
ben i've read a bit of stuff he looks
like he's going off the deep end lately
in terms of uh
um you know coveted conspiracy theories
tied in with his like oh there's state
overreach stuff so
you know they're all different people
right
all right uh cowan what's your take on
karl marx i mean what's my take on karl
marx karl marx was a philosopher
and he's got interesting things to say i
mean we got to get a bit more specific
than that because there's there's an
awful lot right
um
azazel thoughts on star trek the new
generation okay so that's that's
interesting um
i like it when it first came out i did
not like it because i am what you could
call
when it comes to
like innovation or you know adding new
things um i i've been pretty
conservative in the classic sense right
of being like oh the older stuff was
better
and i was a huge fan of the original
series when i was um
you know like uh
i guess i'd be a teenager i started
watching it in the summers because it
was in
reruns and i thought it was great and i
would read the star trek books too
and i don't think i saw some of the real
flaws with it
in the
80s when when i was watching those and
then you know the new generation
came out and i was like i don't like
this you know
uh i don't like the command structure i
don't like what they're doing
you know and then you know i i warmed up
to it and i came to realize oh actually
this is this is kind of better you know
and um
we watched a number of episodes also of
a voyager
with my kids uh over
a winter break
uh and and summer
and you know it's it's decent uh times
you sometimes you look at it and you're
like yeah this isn't very good they wrap
things up a little bit too too easily
but you can say that about so many space
shows right
so
all right luke says found your series on
kierkegaard's philosophical fragments
two videos in and absolutely fascinated
thanks oh you're very welcome
so um
there's a funny story with that
i originally thought it would take me
like three videos three hour long videos
to do kierkegaard's philosophical
fragments
and so i got into it and i started
filming
and then i came to realize
now i
i've got to devote a lot more time to
this than i i have so far
um
and i got much more granular and it
wound up being seven hours worth of
footage of uh philosophical fragments
and there's still some topics that i
didn't get to either adequately or at
all in in that
that work so
yeah
all right um
just skipped a little bit i'm gonna
scroll back up
um
dylan answer familiar with pan psychism
what's your general opinion
yeah i'm familiar with pan psychism how
could you be on philosophy twitter and
not be given all the debates that have
taken place about it
pan psychism holds essentially that
everything has some sort i mean it's
sort of like
in a way it's what we used to call
animism uh when we would talk about you
know religious ideas and we usually
locate animism at the bottom of a
thing pan psychism is supposed to be a
more sophisticated version
where everything has
some kind of
consciousness or awareness or something
like that i mean i find it very
implausible
so
i don't spend much time on it
um
all right
blue glass thoughts on the problem of
evil very much like the problem of free
will or the problem of this or the
problem of that you got to define what
you mean by it because people have meant
a bunch of different things if you're
talking about the traditional you know
why is there evil if there is an
omnipotent omniscient all good god
i would say it's a poorly framed
problem that when we like look at a
concrete world and
you know people's actual views about god
it usually winds up either deepening
uh
in a
proper way like in dostoyevsky for
example or it winds up being very
trivialized
um
so
all right um
larry says your nietzsche is good thanks
yeah i i you know i try not to shoot
videos on people that i don't know
something about so
hopefully it is
um
let's see here violets guy i'm from
wales i too like ham and pineapple pizza
thank you for your work online you know
it's kind of funny because i actually
people say where are you where are you
from where'd you grow up
and sometimes i'll say whales but i
don't mean the same whales that you do i
grew up
west of here about uh 30 miles um
on the border of the village of wales
which was settled by welsh people here
in wisconsin there were a lot of welsh
miners
and there are there's street signs and
you know uh that have like a dra the
welsh dragon on them and some of them
have you know welsh names and i played
for a soccer team called the whales
dragons you know and we had like this
dragon
uh
on our thing you know everything was
very
very welsh oriented out there
um
obviously you know i never learned speak
welsh or anything like that but i always
thought it was kind of cool
um
let's see
jeremy says have you ever had ass in the
tub hot sauce
no i'm not a hot sauce uh connoisseur
you know um
that my wife is more into hot sauces
than i am
um but i've never even heard of that one
but there's like you know hundreds of
varieties of hot sauce out there
uh ricky is nietzsche a good place to
start when it comes to understanding
morality no i wouldn't say so i mean
you can certainly understand nietzsche's
point of view on morality but um
nietzsche
is pretty polemical towards um a lot of
you know traditional forms of morality
i don't know where you would actually
start you know maybe like reading around
in the history of philosophy but also
you know a lot of morality is coming
from other sources as well
elon how do you deal with the magnitude
of information out there i'm feeling
kind of overwhelmed at the moment can't
really decide how to progress i'm going
through a read list but i'm looking for
a more systematic way it depends on what
kind of information you're talking about
i mean you can't you know one of the
things we have to realize today is that
you cannot take in all the information
that's available
so you got to figure out you know where
you're going to get your information
from and hopefully have a wide variety
of more or less reliable sources
you know if you're talking about like
studying philosophy
then you can't study everybody either
and
you know you just sort of do your best
you you know you can presume that that
that plato guy is probably worth reading
and aristotle and some other people
along the way but everybody's reading
list is going to be a bit different than
everybody else's you know
uh max
as someone who almost finished their
first year of learning mandarin chinese
i wanted to ask what do you think of
people who claim they're hyper polyglots
i would say they're braggarts and just
ignore them you know
people who build their identity around
claiming to be polymaths or you know
hyper polyglots or whatever they're
usually people who are kind of you know
full of [ __ ]
and
often have kind of uh irritating
personalities that
um make them prone to trying to like get
into dominant struggles or stuff like
that don't even bother with those people
if you don't have to
um
they're they're kind of a waste of
everybody's time you know they're sort
of like that that guy
that all of us have or could be a woman
in our family who you tell a story and
they've always got a better story you
know
not really worth your time you know
all right um
how to study logic my first year final
logic examination wasn't very good
a lot of logic is just practicing doing
problems over and over again you get
better at it just like you do with
mathematics
there isn't a how to study logic there
are lots of different approaches and
lots of different textbooks but they all
require you to like work your way
through them in
a methodical way
so sorry to hear your test didn't go
that good but i don't know what to tell
you about that
um peter doran do you find actor network
theory to be helpful in thinking about
the structures behind human interaction
no because i don't use it so
i'd have to actually use it to find it
useful i think right
um
now jeremy who's
who's a trucker has some good advice for
any of you who are here in the midwest
mother bears in bloomington indiana is
real good pizza okay so that's you know
southern indiana and then tyrone's in
evansville indiana so if you're in
indiana now you've got a couple good
recommendations
for
for um
pizza places
ben has a really interesting question
here what was the best year of your life
and why
so
that's a tough one
um
i mean i can look back i mean i'm
tempted to say the last year of my life
um
because it's the closest i mean even
though it had tragedy
you know we lost sassy just last month
my um
19 year old our 19 year old
cat who is
my my companion very close to me um
and yet you know um
we've got to spend a lot of good time
together taking walks going out on the
deck
doing things
you know
i don't know that like career-wise one
year was
in retrospect better than another i mean
i could like look back and say well 2008
because i gave the saint anselm lecturer
which was a great honor
yeah but you know those those things
kind of pale over time they look real
important when they're happening
but
with time you're like yeah that was cool
but
just so cool you know i you know
my wife and i married
um over 10 years ago
but um
you know the last two years our marriage
has been
stronger and and better than it it was
when we first got married
um and that's you know hopefully the way
it is for most people right
um
you know my daughter's been up here my
oldest daughter's been up here at
college
at uw milwaukee so i've gotten to see
her a lot more recently i mean it's it's
kind of hard to say right so maybe maybe
the last year was the best year
um
i you know in the last year i've gotten
myself into better shape other than you
know finally catching kovid
i lost uh
40 pounds you know added a lot of
dropped a lot of fat added a lot of
muscle
um
so i don't know these are tough things
to think about right
david what philosophy is best for the
changing time to come in the us with the
with the supreme court taking the rights
of a woman i don't know that there's a
best philosophy i mean
it's not like philosophy is a uh
you know
it's not like a philosophy is like a
checklist that you know fits into
certain things i mean you could start
out you could be a stoic and be a shitty
stoic
and
have a terrible time with it or you
could be an epicurean and really apply
epicurus's ideas well even though
they've got limitations and come up
better than the stoic you know it all
depends on
how well you're you're applying it i
suppose you know um i mean there are
some philosophies that are probably not
going to be particularly
helpful you know but um
if we're talking about philosophies as
ways of life
you know i would say the key is to like
you know do the things that they they
value like thinking through things
prudentially and rationally right
um
john s how many types of love do you
think there are i don't think that
there's a whole bunch of different types
of love that are radically distinct from
each other and people who spend a lot of
time you know
talking about
uh
philia versus eros versus agape are
usually
kind of second or third rate thinkers
um because you know you look at plato
and the symposium he uses these terms
and he just or the republic and he jumps
from one to the other he's not worried
about that sort of thing aristotle
himself is not particularly worried
about that either you know
erotic relationships are a typophilia um
so you know i wouldn't get too too
worried about that
um
orlando have you ever had the
opportunity to read uh churron i haven't
read sharon yet so
um
caesar says cool coffee mug yeah i mean
it's just something that my wife bought
where is this from
high wave i mean she bought it
this is a funny story
so we had these other things from bed
bath and beyond just plain white coffee
mugs
and
i spilled coffee one time too many for
my wife you know and it's understandable
we live in an apartment with like you
know cream-colored carpet floors coffee
is
you know a staining thing that requires
a lot to get out of the carpet
and i think my wife doesn't like it when
i'm clumsy
so she got me she she got us these right
and these
you can look at it and you can tell it's
like
it's got a flat bottom
not a curved bottom and
its center of gravity is much more
towards the
bottom
you really have to work to tip them over
so yeah
um ariel have you read eugene thacker's
horror philosophy books i think they're
pretty enjoyable no i haven't i don't
actually know anything about them but
they sound kind of interesting
um
here's a cyrillic name i really should
learn to read
like actually figure out what what the
cyrillic characters are so i can i can
at least say people's names
uh good afternoon professor i've been
getting deeper into aristotle's
metaphysics i find it very rewarding do
you have the same impression during
readings of aristotle much love and
respect
yeah i mean i
i think i may have mentioned this before
when i was an undergraduate um
we read bits of aristotle's metaphysics
uh
part of the nico mccain ethics
i think maybe part of the politics
and i thought that aristotle was so damn
boring you know i i just didn't get why
people thought he was oh and we read the
categories too
i couldn't figure out why people thought
he was so important it was like a lot of
this stuff is just kind of either common
sense or just wrong
and it's so dry and dull and then i got
into graduate school and i started
rereading aristotle and then i started
learning greek and reading aristotle in
the greek and i was like holy crap this
is amazing stuff there's some really
cool things here
and i've been a huge fan of aristotle
ever since i mean i don't i don't buy
everything that he has to say but i i
think that he's a he's a great thinker
and i i really enjoy
uh reading his works and talking about
them and teaching them and stuff like
that so yeah
i do have the same impression
uh laura tennyson what do you think of
the scientism of writers like jonathan
height malcolm gladwell etc seems to me
like an extension of human human and
empiricism to some degree
i would say it's not even human
empiricism i think hume would criticize
them and say that they're they're you
know
half rate thinkers malcolm gladwell is
i i just find his his stuff
um
i would say almost frankly irritating
he's so swarmy and
jonathan height you know i mean people
like were recommending uh the moral mind
and i was like jesus christ this
dualistic [ __ ] that he he
extrapolates from stuff which he
actually didn't turn out to be uh
right in many respects um i don't know
why
people buy into these these uh
you know essentially
schematic
well i i do know why people there's a
lot of people out there who like
crappy
watered down
you know not quite philosophy
uh and you know the new york times and
other places are are populated by people
like that who then put them on the you
know
book review list and stuff like that so
um jack
has thoughts on drug legalization versus
decriminalization versus criminalization
well i mean criminalization is the
the status quo isn't it
where we are currently so
um and then decriminalization and
legalization how do you draw the line
between them i guess decriminalization
is it's still
um on the books illegal but you're not
going to prosecute sort of like here in
milwaukee you know the cops are unless
you're like acting like a jerk the cops
are not going to go after you for your
little bit of pot but if they find that
you've got a good bit of pot they might
get you on intent to distribute
and you know even more so if you've got
harder drugs
um i mean the war on drugs has clearly
been not only a failure
but has had all sorts of spillover
effects in destroying so many people's
lives and allowing
all sorts of other
things like corruption and racism and
exploitation to flourish
it's been devastating on our city of
milwaukee
i'm not for decriminalization of all
drugs i don't want to say yeah let's
let's decriminalize pcp you know um but
marijuana yeah i mean i'm i'm fine with
that you know
so is my dad by the way who's a former
police chief and it's interesting
because he he realizes that when he
hangs out with other
uh active or former police chiefs that
most of them are nut jobs when it comes
to drugs they're like no zero tolerance
and he's like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you people can't you see the
effects that this has had this has been
a failure we need to change things you
know
[Music]
all right um
cj what do you think the history of
ideas in the 21st century will look like
any trends or thought of thinkers you
think will have set up the tone
i hear the term delusion century
occasionally
yeah i don't think it's going to be a
delusion century that's a great question
i mean i
i don't know
who the
trends are going to be and it's kind of
funny because we're 22 years in now
right so presumably we should have some
pretty well developed trends i mean
somebody mentioned object-oriented
ontology
earlier i think that's going to be
always a minor kind of school just like
you know radical orthodoxy was big in
early 2000s and now it's basically just
like a bunch of you know people that are
that are into that sort of thing
that's a great question i don't i don't
know
um
i mean i think that the notion of
philosophy is a way of life which by the
way did not originate with pirado but
has been around for a very long time
pier odo just came up with the
catchphrase
i think there's a recognition that
that's important and
you know that's an approach that you can
you can take
to a lot of different
[Music]
philosophical points of view
by the way that would include mcintyre's
tradition constituted inquiry
i don't know that's a that's a really
good question
peter asks what do you think about the
idea of deep learning do you think
machines can mimic the human mind in
respect to learning i think that machine
learning is at best a metaphor
machines aren't learning in any real way
they do have things that they're doing
that are quite interesting but it's not
learning and
we don't even understand fully how
humans learn or how the human brain
works
so let's not pretend that you know
neural networks again total a complete
metaphor right neural networks are not
brain mapping or anything like that
they're optimistic
analogies that people are are making
i don't think that machine learning is
deep learning i think that a lot of
human learning is not deep learning you
know
um
rare cell this what do you think of
hegelian imminent critique and science
of logic that reflects of thinking seems
very important from my reading
of science of logic intro and winfield
um i don't think that imminent critique
is what's going on in um
the uh science of logic
um
you know
it's more of a term that gets gets used
by
uh frankfurt school thinkers
um and it's one of those things that can
mean basically whatever you want it to
mean right i don't
what do i think of it i mean
i don't when somebody brings it up i
don't find it a useful
term it doesn't clarify anything for me
the you know the science of logic is
really quite cool
and worth um reading through
maybe once in your life
um very difficult book more difficult i
think than the phenomenology
um
z how would you define wittgenstein or
you name it phase and how and why did
you come out of it
what is the argument that got you out of
it there isn't an argument that gets you
out of a phase
people are not usually convinced by
single arguments they're convinced by a
whole bunch of things put together which
may include some philosophical arguments
but i'm not sure why would we define a
phase
it doesn't seem like the sort of thing
that you define
um
so i'm not quite sure what you're asking
all right uh philip if some people seek
validation of their viewpoint or general
affect of state from second or third
rate philosophers then what is it one
should optimally seek for in philosophy
well yeah
you said it reading first-rate
philosophers
i mean there's nothing wrong with
reading second and third-rate
philosophers just don't pretend that
they are you know
what what philosophy has to offer to you
unless you want to have a stunted
existence you know and hang out with
other people who have a similarly
stunted existence
we've got this wonderful opportunity i
mean we live in a time where we have so
much access
online
to so many great philosophers works and
you know so many things are
translated or in translation so if you
can't read
you know ancient greek you know like i
was writing about simplicius's
commentary on epic epictetus's end
coridian today
and you know i can read epictetus is
greek and i can read some plickeus
it's slower going than reading it in
english translation so how nice that
it's actually
available and i can purchase it you know
fairly cheaply from bloomsbury um
why would you why would you you know i
mean just read the really good stuff
right
so
all right it just skipped again um
and we're about uh an hour and ten
minutes
in so i'm not i'm definitely not going
to get to everybody's questions as you
know we never do but i'll try to pick
some people who haven't been picked
before
and uh
oh tf is a good one could you speak to
any flaws you find in mcintyre's after
virtue it's a flaw that not only have i
found but anthony long
found and wrote an entire awesome
article about
mcintyre gets the stoics wrong mcintyre
also to some degree gets kierkegaard
wrong so much so that that kierkegaard
scholars actually had an entire edited
volume
on where mcintyre is getting kierkegaard
wrong and after virtue and where he's
getting him right and mcintyre himself i
think wrote a piece responding to it so
you could say in in parts of mcintyre's
history there's
there's things there's parts where he
has not given
you could say adequate treatment to um
some of the authors and he's fine with
admitting that i've actually written a
piece uh which you can find in my
academia.edu thing that i presented at
the
uh
the
international society for mcintyre and
inquiry when it was in grand rapids so
that would be like 2013
talking about um how he
missed an opportunity for
seeing anselm as somebody
uh engaging in the kinds of things that
he he's talking about in in his work so
there's a lot of things along those
lines i think he's a little bit too um
bullish on the
you know aristotelian thing and you know
we should probably also think about
other
important currents and this is this is
the point that anthony long was making
that the stoics
you know at least the serious ones
constitute a rival similar
tradition
within uh late modernity that is doing
some of the things that that mcintyre
saying aristotelians ought to be doing
um and i i would argue that um
platonists are as well believe it or not
so
all right uh metrodorus how do you feel
about deism i mean it's interesting i'm
not a deist uh i think i think you know
if we're talking about like thomas payne
style deism it's
interesting but ultimately
unsatisfactory
um
descartes was probably a deist in in you
know he
he claims to be a catholic but i don't i
don't think he really is
um
so you know it's a point of view that
people have had
i don't find it particularly
attractive
um
arthur montana are you familiar with
moral realism
is it an extreme form of moral
relativism
chris ann moore referenced in her
lecture on selfism moral realism is one
of those terms that means different
things to different people
so i don't know who
chris ann moore is
but it's it's moral realism
is usually going to be
opposed to any sort of relativism it's
the idea in general that like
i mean some people explain like well
there's moral facts or you know at least
there's values out there somewhere in
the universe
uh and we can you know the mind can
grasp them which by the way to mention
deism deism
uh of the thomas paine variety uh rests
on that that very basis if you look at
the age of reason
um
so you know there's there's different um
different versions of it out there you
know
um
keaton says getting into kierkegaard and
really feeling that dread and angst any
advice yeah
kierkegaard thinks that that's great
um if you're you know if you're
following along with him and he's he's
making you feel
dread or anxiety uh which basically you
know are the same thing just different
translations of the same term
you're on the right track now you need
to figure out where you're going to go
with that right
[Music]
let's see mashy thoughts on
psychoanalysis and freud okay so that's
that's a good one um
i think that there's some things that
freud uh
you know i won't say he got like 100
right but he's on he's on the right
track william james by the way says that
as well in his uh
um
his chapter on conversion in um
uh
varieties of religious experience right
along with a whole bunch of other
psychologists of the time
um he thinks that this notion of like
the subconscious or unconscious there's
something to that and i i kind of think
there's there's there's something there
you know i'm i'm more
a fan of lacan's
uh treatment of that then i am like a
jungian collective unconscious with
archetypes and shadows and all that sort
of [ __ ]
um
and you know it's important to keep in
mind that freud thought that
psychotherapy
was not something just to generate ideas
and cool theories and stuff like that
it was to try to
make people's lives less miserable
so you know and there's a lot of
different
you know methods and
schools and traditions in psychoanalysis
so if you're asking like about reich's
stuff
you know which veers off into crazy land
i'm not a fan of that right
if you're asking about um you know young
not a fan of jung although i like
reading jung's books
um you know and there's all sorts of
people who've drawn on freud
some of his ideas like the oedipus
complex
um
you're like yeah i don't i don't really
buy that and even lacan doesn't doesn't
buy that he he he relativizes the
oedipus complex in one of his uh
seminars
saying that
it's basically at best something that
would be characteristic of a certain
time in western modernity
but you know freud is worth reading you
you obviously shouldn't become like a
freudian
and buy into everything that the guy
says because some of the things he says
likes many philosophers are kind of
ridiculous you know
jane toms
how would you refute descartes dream
argument against the eternal world i
would read the rest of descartes
meditations where he does refute it
you know
um
orlando oh here's a great star trek
question who is the better captain kirk
picard
um most of the captains are better
captains than kirk in retrospect kirk is
an [ __ ] he's he's egotistical he
makes stupid decisions you know he's
he's not a good leader in general
i mean
um
picard you know you can always find
fault with anybody right but picard is
like
way way above kirk in terms of being a
better leader i would actually say
that
kirk
um
has
officers under him who are better
leaders than kirk himself you know
so
all right uh
mf do you think going into creative
writing a certificate is a good way to
get better at writing or is it a waste
of money
for context i used to write a lot but
had to stop for two months bout of
depression it totally depends on the
program
and who's teaching it and stuff like
that there's no
there's no simple answer to that um
i would i would look you know very
closely at
who are the the people who are the
teachers or instructors and faculty
involved in the program right and then
look for
any sort of like critiques or
testimonials
that you can find from people who've
gone through the the program and this
this holds by the way not just for
writing but really anything that you
want to study
um it before you start trusting somebody
with your time and your brain and your
money
you want to see what
other people who have studied with them
have to say about them and and they
there might be some like off the wall
really super negative stuff or super
positive stuff just discount that and
look for like the
the middle of the road kind of things
all right um
we got about 10 minutes left so i'm
gonna jump around again try to take just
questions from people who haven't had a
a chance to um
to uh
ask one so mark says given the evolving
paradigm shift from einsteinian physics
to quantum physics of today
is is it plausible that the many worlds
interpretation may have some merit
sure why not you know i mean
it's all pretty hypothetical
um
sam how does one go about arranging an
individual tutorial for you you go to
the reason io.com website and there's a
a tab under services for tutorials i
mean there's also a link to it in most
of my videos
as well
um
[Music]
let's see here
atis says sometimes you read something
you instantly agree with the author's
worldview and you feel him
which philosopher has been the exact
opposite you read it again still did not
get it
that's a good question i mean i haven't
had that experience
lately
i mentioned like aristotle you know when
i was an undergraduate reading aristotle
i was like why would anyone want to read
this crap why why does anybody think
this this guy is important
and then
it happened i i did get it you know
um
so i mean that might be an example of
that
um
ron asks have you read eric fromms the
art of loving if so do you believe his
interpretation of love is something at
least to consider it most integrate it's
been a long time since i've read it i
mean i was in graduate school when i
read it
and
i remember liking it but i can't
remember too much about what his
position was so
yeah
um
bob asks a good question here do you
think professors who try to strive for
some extent for political neutrality in
college classrooms are taking a valid
approach
yes
um
but that political neutrality should be
an engaged neutrality where you like you
know you're not just saying oh i'm not
going to say anything about this
everybody's opinion is just as good as
everybody else's
and there probably should be some like
you know things you're like listen this
that this thing that you're trying to do
in the class we're not gonna we're not
gonna tolerate this
um so
neutrality can come in different forms
it can be the what about ism that
doesn't do anybody any good you know
both sides are equally bad well there
might be five different sides and maybe
they aren't all equally good or bad but
here's what i always said i mean because
i i teach whether we're talking about
political or we're talking about other
things
when i'm teaching a religious studies
class somebody shouldn't know you know
whether i'm a committed religious person
or not
i should present the stuff as
objectively as i can
and going into going into things
thoughtfully right if i'm going to
present a position i should consider
whether there's any whether there's any
um counter positions to it that have
merit you know and look at things that
way and so i think professors can do
that
a lot of times students are not
particularly well qualified to determine
whether a professor
is being neutral or not i would say
um
io dr sandler how would you summarize
the philosophy behind the prince of
nothing trilogy and how does that apply
if it does to the days we're living in
so this is the r scott backer uh his
first three books in the second
apocalypse series
which ends in a heartbreaking way by the
way with book seven
um
i think that bocker
at at his core
is actually he's got sort of a
and unfortunately and i think in his
view unfortunately
nihilistic perspective and i think he's
grappling with some of the same
sort of problems
that
nietzsche's work is
um
it's a very dark world
in which um
magic or sorcery exists and there's
several different races
of beings
including the non-men
who were
there before human beings became
civilized
um
and um there's all sorts of really
interesting things
being sort of worked with experimented
with in blockers
works and there's all sorts of
philosophical
reflections and dialogues going on in it
as well and it's concerned with you know
questions like is there a point to
history
can we move towards a better jester
world or is that always going to be just
some somebody's perspective on that how
to power
and
goodness come together if they do you
know
so
yeah they're well worth exploring i'm
going to be doing some writing over the
summer about um those first three books
by the way starting
with the metaphor
of the the open step and
the
um nihilism
that canaas
lapses into
because of calhous and then later
because of um
uh his his son
um
working together with these these ideas
so yeah all right um
what else can we find by
somebody i haven't taken a
question from before um
so
let's see here
so sam has got is like doing some side
chatter about um
tutorial sessions
do that in email that's not something
you do here in in um
[Music]
a philosophy chat right
um
let's see here ryan says i was wondering
what your opinion on friedrich jameson
and his works is post-modernism is a
really good book um
you know that's well worth reading
through
um jameson you know he's doing sort of
high theory stuff right
so
um
that's you know
he's he's worth reading he's pretty
demanding
to to read so
uh spoon man what do you think of
bataille it seems like academia has
dismissed him as a merely literary freak
figure with little philosophical insight
i don't know that academia has done that
i think most academia doesn't pay any
attention to bataille but most academia
doesn't pay any attention to any
particular
figure except the ones that they're
working on
um but tai is somebody who's you know
viewed as a thinker and continental
philosophy
he's got a number of different works
that people
read there's not a ton of bataille
scholars out there but there's not a ton
of leotard scholars out there and you
know he's just not a super popular
figure right now
he's certainly fun to read i i enjoy him
you know
um
all right who else uh
haven't i
taken
um
[Music]
somebody's yelling out out there
oh here's a good one um
again from
abe manu how many hours should a
philosophy student study
a day
depends on what you're studying depends
on how what you have available there
isn't a like this is the right amount
some people need more time to
read a work than other people do
it all depends on
what you've got available you know there
isn't a
hard and fast answer to that and there
there isn't a hard and fast answer for
most things i'll go out on this one by
alex fernandez do you have a routine or
way of getting into a new philosopher
no i don't have a routine or way i get
their works and then i read them
and
maybe some people would benefit from
having a routine so here's what i'm
going to say about that
we don't all have to do philosophy the
same way
and
there's a legitimate plurality of
approaches not just in terms of like
schools or methodologies
but even in terms of this sort of thing
like how many hours a day should i study
or you know what what sort of way should
i approach this person's works
these are not things that have a
single answer and i would
here's here's how i'll end beware of
people who are very confidently telling
you this is the way it has to be done
you must read heidegger in this way or
you're not understand anything
they're usually wrong or they're selling
some package
that they they want you to purchase
or they're trying to get you know uh as
we call it clout or prestige you know
you don't have to listen to them you you
try out what works for you and see
what works best for you and and try
multiple modes of doing things and you
know some of them are going to be
failures for you and they may might not
be failures for other people but if it's
a failure for you then it's not working
for you right and the things that are
successful for you well keep on doing
those right now you know that maybe i do
need to take notes i'm not a note taker
but a lot of people out there really
benefit from taking notes right so i'm
not going to say because i don't take
notes you shouldn't take notes
it all depends on your
temperament and your way of learning and
stuff like that so
i got to do another
event
at the top of the hour so i'm going to
say
goodbye to all of you and thanks um
i'll see you i do have another uh
streaming event coming up tomorrow stoic
sundays we're going to be looking at the
virtue of justice so if you're into that
sort of thing find that on my channel
otherwise i'll i'll see all of you
somewhere else have a good
evening those of you further
east good uh
morning maybe or even middle of the
night for those further west
and
i'll see you next time